[Music]
you've heard a lot about our failing
institutions on this program we now know
the FBI is riddled with incompetent
partisan hacks the intelligence
community seems to exist mostly to spy
on you and leaked information about
politicians it dislikes your state and
local governments are full of
bureaucrats who are paid more to deliver
less every year and then retire with a
fat pension in their 50s academia
meanwhile is apparently dominated by
lazy mediocrities more interested in
political activism than in teaching
there is a lot of rot in our halls of
power but our federal courts may be the
most decayed institution of although
they received very little attention over
the last two administrations the courts
increasingly have come to see themselves
not as interpreters of the law their
constitutional role but as the country's
main policymakers consider for example
what's been happening with daca now as a
factual matter it is indisputable that
any president has the authority to end
daca the program was a creation from
whole cloth the Obama administration it
has no legal basis actual federal law
says that illegal immigrants are to be
deported from this country not given
legal residency or work permits the
above administration simply chose to
ignore that law setting the right of
prosecutorial discretion now the
argument could be valid theoretically
that we are skeptical but here's what we
know if Obama can choose to ignore the
law it is obvious that Trump
administration has the right to enforce
the law the law passed by Congress and
yet left-wing judges disagree several
have ruled already it is somehow illegal
to andhaka their justification for this
is legally ludicrous last month San
Francisco district court judge William
also blocked the end of daca nationwide
he said getting rid of it was quote
arbitrary and capricious as part of his
ruling also simply asserted that daca
should continue because it was quote in
the public interest in other words the
judge likes the program therefore ending
it is illegal last week another judge
judged Nicholas Garrity's in New York
ruled that daca can't be eliminated
because the administration has not
provided a valid reason for eliminating
it as if following the law were not
enough ends up the first bizarre
from that judge in 2010 Gareth has
ordered the New York Fire Department to
use racial quotas for hiring rather than
merit in order to achieve some goals he
had in mind and the results were
immediate injuries in the fire
department went up the dropout rate of
firemen in that class surged from 10% to
24% in a later reversal an appeals court
said the Gera phasis bias was so obvious
and so severe the parts of the case had
to be assigned to a new judge then of
course Gera FFA's is still on the bench
he and a lot of judges like him in
Michigan a judge has blocked the
deportation of convicted Iraqi criminals
from this country citing the alleged
danger they would face if they returned
to their own country in New York a judge
released an illegal immigrant criminal
prior to deportation claiming he had a
constitutional right to quote say
goodbye in Florida a judge blocked the
deportation of nearly a hundred Somalis
because of the conditions on the
airplane that would fly them home for
real that happened this sort of thing is
actually commonplace now in the name of
progressive resistance to the president
anything can be declared
unconstitutional and is for example it's
been settled law pretty much forever
that a president has the power to
exclude foreigners from the country
based on security concerns but in the
past year multiple judges have ignored
this and struck down the
administration's travel bans some have
taken the legally meaningless position
that the bans were unconstitutional
because of things Trump said on the
campaign trail Judge James Wynn of the
Fourth Circuit compared the president's
travel ban to FDR's internment of the
Japanese American citizens of Japanese
descent during the Second World War
that's not legal analysis is political
punditry get that man a CNN contract for
more than 200 years the US military
determined who could serve in uniform
based in part on which medical
conditions might negatively affect a
person's ability to fight wars and there
are a lot of them that make sense of
course it's no longer the law thanks to
judges in his final months in office
President Obama declared the military
must admit transgendered soldiers
regardless of the effect on military
readiness that was a political decision
obviously but thanks to activist judges
it is now a constitutional right somehow
judges Marvin Garbus of Maryland and
Colleen Collard caudally of
District of Columbia have ruled that
it's unconstitutional to bar
transgendered volunteers from service
Garbus is ruling went on to order the
government to cover gender reassignment
surgery at taxpayer expense these judges
are not interpreting the law much less
enforcing it they are inventing the law
they reject the core idea of democracy
which is a country whose policies are
determined by its citizens its voters
the judges are in control no matter what
you want or who you voted for
increasingly the elected branches of
government are irrelevant this is
especially true in the issue of
immigration as we said in 1980s a
limited amnesty for farmworkers was
supposed to end in 1988 the courts ruled
it had to be extended further as a
result thousands of additional people
were given amnesty they weren't supposed
to receive lawmakers were ignored in the
1990s California voters overwhelmingly
passed Proposition 187 but denied state
social services to people here illegally
courts gutted that law without even
allowing it to take effect
and now California's entire middle class
is fleeing the state because the illegal
immigration has made it a dystopia
suitable only for the very poor in the
very rich that's exactly what voters
didn't want what the vote didn't care so
how long before some judge on the Ninth
Circuit for example decides the illegal
aliens have the right to vote in our
elections because well just because you
can laugh if you want but on some level
you know that's coming because it is in
a functioning Constitution Republic
judges are essential their job is to
restrain politicians from trampling our
core governing principles and by core
governing principles we mean the ones
written in the Constitution not in the
New York Times editorial page or at the
base of the Statue of Liberty our system
has worked well for hundreds of years
but it's breaking apart and is breaking
apart because of judicial integrity
there isn't enough of that if you find
yourself arguing that the Constitution
does not contain the right to keep and
bear arms but does contain a right to
abortion you're lying it's not a
difference of interpretation it's
dishonesty one is in the text one is not
right now this is happening almost
exclusively on the left but it's not
hard to imagine conservatives doing it
too why wouldn't they after a while what
happens when Republican appointed judges
start striking down laws a Democratic
Congress passed on taxes or health care
the environment abortion
you name it simply because they don't
like them the judiciary will lose
whatever honor at once had it will
become a political weapon that has
happened in a lot of countries and it's
a disaster every time judges who misuse
their power ought to be called to
account they're not gods they're
government officials who work for us and
when they're corrupt or dishonest they
ought to face the same criticism as
politicians or bureaucrats Abraham
Lincoln understood this he accused the
high courts chief justice of plotting to
spread slavery throughout America
Lincoln is praised by historians for
doing that because he was right but when
this administration points out judicial
malfeasance and there's a lot of it the
ruling class responds with howls that's
an attack on democracy they say I find
these attacks on the judiciary
absolutely unacceptable I'll be honest I
don't understand language like that we
don't have Saul caught the so-called
judges we don't have so-called senators
we don't have so-called presidents
so-called judge is it appropriate for
the president to be questioning the
legitimacy of a federal judge in that
way doesn't that undermine the
separation of powers and the
Constitution written right next door
they're lying to you as they always are
it's not anti-democratic to demand that
the public's view should fundamentally
shape public policy that's the essence
of democracy itself Jonathan Turley is a
particularly distinguished professor at
George Washington University Law School
and he joins us tonight professor thanks
for coming up Thanks
so that's kind of the essence of the
whole debate as to what extension public
policy be guided by the public's views
in a democracy and obviously there are
mediating structures the Congress the
judiciary the executive but basically if
you get too far from what the public
wants it's not democracy is it well we
of course live in a representative
democracy we with the you elect people
to make decisions for you but you
hopefully won't have too much of a
disconnect at the end of the day between
the policies being pursued ultimately
those laws have to be written by people
who are political representatives
exactly and that means that the courts
must retain a fairly narrow rule a role
a role in this system otherwise system
doesn't work you know Madison created a
system by which factional interests
would sort of roll around between the
legislative and executive
the branch particularly in Congress and
out of that would come what's called a
majoritarian compromise so we work out
our differences that system only works
if there's no alternative to that system
if you start to make decisions for
example in the courts that are really
political decisions it takes the
medicine system offline and that's what
has given us a stability you know you
you have countries like France that went
through constitutions with almost a
seasonal regularity and they were very
unstable ours has been stable you could
say a lot of things about problems that
we have but we're still here we've we've
gone through incredible pressures and
Men and periods and we're still here and
it's largely due to the fact that we all
have sort of skin in the game we all
know that if we respect the political
system that is worth working for change
yes right I agree with that completely
and I have always believed in our system
and I want to believe in it but if you
have judges who clearly aren't even
making a good-faith effort to pretend
that their decisions correspond to the
text of the Constitution then don't the
rest of us have a right to say something
about that well I think that there's
there's no problem with criticizing the
courts and every president in modern
times has taken the courts to task and
they've all pledged to change the courts
on the left or the right that's a
natural part of the process there are
times when you cross the line I greatly
approve the president's criticism of the
ethnicity of that one judge across the
line I hated those words I agree with
you I hated that but that doesn't mean
that if a judge doesn't see the right to
bear arms which is written explicitly in
the bill of rights but somehow imagines
you know the right to abortion which of
course is nowhere to be found
does that rate I mean we take it for
granted but it's very common doesn't
that raise the question like what well I
think that people of good faith can
disagree on these issues yes issues of
the second amendment abortion these are
all penumbral issues although the Second
Amendment is expressed but in terms of
abortion that the court refers to is of
a sort of a penumbra right and we could
disagree about those things and we can
do so civilly but there's no problem
with with with citizens or president
saying
that's just not what the law says that's
not what we created as a free plate and
we're in charge George Stephanopoulos
does not like it if you say that though
so just keep that in mind if you dare
professor thank you thank you